welcome back the holidays are all about
indulging and finding any moment to cut
back on calories that can be a true
blessing yes and my little minks of a
mixologist rossi ross matthews here is
going to show us how to make some
healthy holiday cocktails that won't tip
the scale that is right you know i've
got a few recipes that are so yummy and
the dewberry more show has teamed up
with sodastream to bring them to life
and our first cocktail i made just for
you you know what it's called what the
drew barrymore
yes so
we're gonna start by bubbling our water
drew you already have some pre-bubbled
water over there sodastream turns plain
water into fresh sparkling water in just
seconds at the push of a button so i'm
going to insert this here look how cool
this is this is just plain water and
then i'm going to press this three times
because i like it extra fizzy
me too i want it to sting yeah well
listen i want like oh yeah yes i want a
really strong tight fit yeah i love a a
big bubble all right next i'm going to
flavor my water with a little uh
raspberry bubbly drop just a little bit
and now this is calorie-free and
sugar-free as well how about that yours
is already flavored
next let me actually mix it a little bit
like this
then i'm going to set it aside oh this
smells so beautiful yeah it's the
raspberry i know oh my gosh so now i
want you to take your cup and put some
berries in there i have blackberries
blueberries raspberries you could do
whatever you want strawberries and then
i'm going to muddle them and that's just
a fancy word for smushing it look
you can get your aggression out a little
bit
okay now i'm going to put a couple ice
cubes in
look
um now i'm going to put a shot of vodka
in mine because ha ha
ha ha
yeah
and then we're gonna take our
sparkling water with our berry flavoring
fill it up
look at the color how gorge right oh i
want some ice and then
i just like to garnish it
with a little mint right there and how
gorgeous is this
calories friendly
cheers rossy here's drew
what do you think
this
is
everything this is so beautiful it's
fruity it's refreshing it's herbaceous
it's delicious gosh cheers
this is a drew barrymore okay
also i want to say something that is
important to me now
is that sodastream also um is very
environmentally friendly oh my gosh
because you stopped buying all the
bottles and cans yes this comes with it
right so you're just using the bottle
the same bottle
every time you make it and it's um
affordable
it's cost effective it's really
beautiful too all right i have another
recipe for you as well recipe okay ready
for this one
it is called
the rose matthews
oh no yes oh yes i did so i'm gonna take
i have a champagne flute here it's just
a wine glass but like taller
i'm gonna just fill this up halfway with
some rose just any rose that you like
okay you have a fose over there i have a
pose
and then remember our raspberry
sparkling water yes i do okay so i'm
gonna fill the rest of the glass up with
that okay hold on
okay ooh look
you see those bubbles in there and then
i'm just going to garnish it with some
pomegranate seeds on top look how pretty
and festive
this is
cheers
cheers this is
this is
light bubbly slightly fruity it's just
like me
rose matthews
i absolutely love these drinks this for
me is just heaven i love this so much no
it's a this is an easy way to take like
your boring cocktails to the next flavor
level and keep it really healthy and
affordable well cheers to opening my
horizons and expanding them rossi thank
you i really appreciate it cheers
everybody
all right well
ross you know
you like to make healthy choices yes we
do holiday season using sodastream i do
and um i wanted to say to the audience
right now that we would like to
recommend that you do the same because
you're all going home with the newest
latest
[Applause]
okay so this is the new sodastream tara
and it is that gorgeous model that we
were just looking at and i do care about
how things look on your countertop it's
very important to me that it'd be
aesthetically pleasing and this is
absolutely stunning design and think
about all the good it will do by saving
bottles and cans and being more friendly
the
and make those environment
and make those cocktails and mocktails
enjoy happy holidays
[Music]